willkommen liebe Zuschauer bei history
live den historischen Quartett auf
Phoenix Karl der Große einfache darüber
diskutieren wir heute 1200 Jahre nach
seinem Tod mit der Münchner Historikerin
Martina Hartmann dem Heidelberger
Historiker Stefan Weinfurter und dem in
Frankfurt lebenden französischen
Historiker Pierre Monet heute machen wir
mal ganz was anderes liebe Zuschauer wer
war Karl der Große der Begründer der
europäischen Kultur ein hemmungsloser
listling der sich über alles sehr machte
was ein Rock trug ein Sachsen schlechter
wie man ihn im sogenannten Dritten Reich
bezeichnete oder gar der urfranzose wie
er in unserem nachbarlande gern gesehen
wird
keiner große war natürlich von allem was
aber man muss unterscheiden wie die Zeit
Insa was er in der Zeit geleistet hat
und wie ein späteren Jahrhunderten dann
instrumentalisiert wurde oder eingesetzt
wurde und da haben wir natürlich
zunächst mal den Reichsgründer Karl der
ein großes Reich gründet eines das in
dieser Zeit ja größer war als das
byzantinische und im Mittelmeerraum
führend war
und dann haben wir natürlich den
Herrscher der die romanisch antike
Kultur ich sage mal mit der germanischen
muss man ja vorsichtig sein in
Anführungszeichen
naja das Wort Germanen ist natürlich
belastet
ein bisschen traktieren dieses deshalb
sind wir eher geneigt zu sagen das sind
Völker die auf eine romanische Kultur
stoßen und benennen die Völker exakt
woher wissen wir das eigentlich alles
Frau Hartmann die Quellenlage ist ja
doch nicht gerade üppig ja aber so
schlecht ist die Quellenlage auch nicht
denn wir haben zunächst mal die
Lebensbeschreibung eines Augenzeugen
eines Zeitgenossen Karls der ungefähr 20
Jahre jünger war ein hart der auch zum
hofkreis Karls gehört hat und eben nach
dem Tod Karls eine Lebensbeschreibung
uns geliefert hat und die zweite Quelle
die eben jünger ist und wo Karl schon in
das Reich der Legende übergeht ist die
Vita von notgabalbulus die
Lebensbeschreibungen eben der Taten
Karls von nordger und wir haben eben
noch die sogenannten reichsanalen die
eben über die Herrschaft Karl
wie glaubwürdig sind denn diese Quellen
ich meine der gute Einhalt um nur ein
Beispiel zu sagen hat ja schon fast
sowas wie eine heiligen Legende verfasst
sehr Bruno ja schon sehr protomo und
während die ältere Forschung ihm fast
alles geglaubt hat ist die jüngere
Forschung da schon kritischer geworden
und hat von einem Hof Euphemismus
geschrieben und manches in Frage
gestellt aber ich denke es ist nicht zu
bezweifeln dass ein hart vieles über
Karl berichtet was glaubhaft ist es ist
eher so dass er manches weglässt was für
Carl nicht positiv ist wir kommen
vielleicht noch drauf also etwa Karls
Verhältnis zu den Frauen war eben was
was hat nicht gefallen darüber werden
wir natürlich gerne reden warum wurde
oder wird bei ihnen in Frankreich der
Germane ich sag das jetzt mal obwohl das
Wort wie ich höre belastet ist Karl der
Große eigentlich gern als Begründer des
französischen König gesehen und damit
schlecht den als der o-franzose
überhaupt ich meine gar nicht mal die
Wissenschaft sondern das populäre
Geschichtsbild also ich bin zunächst
sehr dankbar dass diese Frage eben in
einer deutschen Sendung gestellt wird
weil man muss auch sagen dass zurzeit
also im Jubiläum ja 1200 Jahre in
Frankreich die Aufmerksamkeit auf Karl
dem Großen nicht so groß ist natürlich
die Öffentlichkeit in Frankreich ist
überschattet von der komiorierung des
Ersten Weltkrieges 1914 aber das sind
bestimmt auch einen anderen Grund und zu
Ihrer Frage dann würde ich mehrere
Antworten
geben für die französischen Könige
Mittelalter bis Ludwig dem 16 war gewiss
Karl der Große ein Gründer der
französischen Monarchie und somit ein
französischer Gründer der französischen
für die Schule der dritten sogar der
Fünften Republik ist Karl der Große es
war ein Franzose gehört zu dieser großen
Tradition hat aber viele Konkurrenz in
Mittelalter zum Beispiel oder auch mit
den Galliern weil natürlich die Pute ist
dass wir in Frankreich sagen die
französische Geschichte als sie früher
als die deutsche Geschichte angefangen
bevor wir jetzt weiter ins Detail gehen
liebe Zuschauer machen wir uns doch erst
einmal die geographische Dimension des
Frankenreiches bewusst wovon sprechen
wir da eigentlich
das reicht des jungen König Karl ist
riesig sein Großvater Karl Martell und
sein Vater König Pippin haben es in
ständigen kriegen enorm vergrößert es
erstreckt sich von Thüringen bis in die
Provence und vom Mittelmeer bis zum
Atlantik und das wurde später noch viel
mehr
Bild und Text stammen übrigens aus der
ersten Folge unserer ZDF-Serie die
deutschen wo wir Karl den Großen ja ganz
bewusst gewisse Maßen an den Anfang der
deutschen Geschichte gestellt haben wie
legitim ist das denn
Karl der Große und die Deutschen ja das
ist natürlich ein Thema dass man
eigentlich gar nicht so angehen dürfte
weil wir in einer Zeit uns befinden in
denen es noch gar keine deutschen gab ja
das ist natürlich immer das Problem für
den Historiker
und das entwickelt sich erst im Lauf der
Zeit dass man überhaupt ein deutsches
Bewusstsein hat oder reich oder
Nationalbewusstsein das sind die
Franzosen schneller aber man wird sagen
können wenn wir von der heutigen
Situation ausgehen und die ja ich sage
jetzt auch die germanische Zuordnung in
den Vordergrund stellen wollen dann
werden wir sagen müssen dass Karl der
Große ein einfachen Franke war ja und
damit eine Romane das hat er auch selbst
sehr stark zu empfunden das war auch für
ihn eine Tatsache die er eigentlich
überwinden wollte er wollte die
romanische Bildung und den normalen
romanischen
naja also Standards Bildung Standard im
Bereich verbreiten das ist das ist alles
klar insofern wird man sagen müssen
von er war kein Romane ist aber später
das heißt relativ rasch dann schon im
Mittelalter zu einem Franzosen
umfunktioniert worden ja das heißt
die deutsche Zuordnung wenn wir das
überhaupt sagen dürfen ist schon sehr
bald im Mittelalter 12 13 14 Jahrhundert
eigentlich schon im 10 jahrhundert
überlagert worden durch die Zuordnung in
die franzia in das Frankenreich weil das
Frankenreich den Namen Franken für sich
abiert hat sich Karl der Große den
subjektiv lieber als Romane verstehen
wollen obwohl er doch eher
generologisch er aus der germanischen
Ecke des Reiches Kamera nee also er hat
natürlich auch viele Jahre in
westlichen Bereichen des großen
Schattenreiches verbracht es hätte auch
sein können dass zum Beispiel am Ende
seines Lebens eher in der großen Abtei
seine nie begraben begraben worden wäre
wo alle französischen Könige auch noch
begraben wurden also das heißt die
Beziehung schon räumlich und zeitlich zu
späteren Frankreich ist auch groß und
ich meine von auch den Reisen abteilen
und auch von den Hof von den Höfling und
auch hofgelehrten ein großer Teil kommt
auch aus diesem Gebiet plus die
lateinische Kultur die natürlich
Frankreich auch teilt mit anderen
abendländischen Ländern versuchen wir
doch beides mal zusammen zu bringen Frau
Hartmann also der Begründer des
französischen königsums und irgendwie
doch Urvater des späteren Heiligen
Römischen Reiches deutscher national
also gleichsam ich mach mal jetzt ganz
populär ein ur Franzose
und ein urdeutschland das wäre ja
praktisch sowas wie eine Mischung aus
Adenauer und de Gaulle ist das nicht
wunderbar
ja aber es ist eben immer problematisch
mit späteren Vorstellungen daran zu
gehen und ich würde eben auch zu Herrn
Monet noch sagen solange Karl expandiert
hat hatte er sicherlich
eher das auch den Westen und natürlich
den Norden mit Sachsen im Blick aber in
seinen späteren Jahren hat er sich doch
sehr bewusst auch auf Aachen
zurückgezogen und es ist ja eben auch
die Frage ob er sich überhaupt später
noch daran erinnert hat dass er in
seiner Jugend mal auch in als es steht
ja in einer Urkunde geschrieben hat dass
er in die nie begraben werden wollte das
ist ja eben was wir nicht wissen hat die
Entscheidung haben die Entscheidungen
die Töchter getroffen als Karl starb
oder wollte er selber in Aachen haben
werden ein zweites Rom geworden war
grafisch sehr gut Aachen ist ja auch von
strategischer Bedeutung wenn man eben
die Ausdehnung dieses R Streiches
anschaut also das ist ja auch mit
heutigen Maßstäben schwer zu begreifen
wir haben in Reich von einer Million
Quadratkilometer und die Entfernung
zwischen Hamburg und Rom sind 1600
Kilometer ein Boote konnte damals
maximal 60 Kilometer am Tag Reisende
sind ja erstmal die geografischen
Dimensionen die man sich überhaupt klar
machen muss was regieren dieses Reiches
überhaupt heißt also karl hat sich ja
selber wohl als Franke verstanden
zunächst und vor allem haben sie ja
gesagt jetzt wollen wir mal wissen
welche Sprache Sprache eigentlich und
aus welcher Ecke seines riesigen Reiches
kam seine Familie umkam vor allem er
ich denke man sollte das schon noch mal
betonen karl war ein Franke das darf man
nicht verwechseln mit dem heutigen
deutschen
frankengebiet Oberfranken Unterfranken
überhaupt nichts zu tun sondern das ist
das reinfränkische Gebiet das auch weit
noch nach Westen hineinreicht und sein
hauptaufenthaltsgebiet das kann man ganz
klar nachweisen von den Stationen her
umfasst etwa das Gebet zu Köln
vielleicht ein bisschen nach Osten hin
aber danach Westen bis etwa Paris Paris
und nach Süden eigentlich bis Metz kann
man sagen ja mit und die Gebete
drumherum also lotdringlich Gebiet
lotdringliches Gebiet heutiges Belgien
und in diesem Raum verbringt er
die meiste Zeit überhaupt seine
Regierung wenn er nicht gerade wieder
auf Kriegszug ist ja aber die übrigen
Reichsteile das fränkischen Reiches
betritt er ganz selten oder überhaupt
nicht er war ganz selten in
Südfrankreich oder ganz selten in in der
in Aquitanien ja das das ist eigentlich
ein relativ begrenzter Bereich den wir
heute natürlich zu Frankreich oder
Belgien rechnen würden aber der damals
höchstens zu einem Mischzone war und ähm
aus diesem Gebiet holt er sich auch die
Frauen würde ich mal sagen im Großen und
Ganzen mit Ausnahme dazu kommt
die Frage wie sprach er denn kann man
das als altfränkisch bezeichnen war das
eine germanische Sprache man spricht
heute eben von der Volkssprache tot ist
wird diese Sprache genannt und das ist
eine Volkssprache eine Vorform des
deutschen aber auch eine Form des
Deutschland natürlich das ist ganz klar
wir neigen dazu dann zu sagen das war
die fränkische bayerische und und
alemannische Sprache aber wir wissen
auch dass diese Sprachen nicht so weit
auseinander waren wie später diese würde
ich mal sagen Dialekte oder die man sie
heute bezeichnen würde die sind relativ
nah beisammen die haben sich alle
wunderbar verstanden und deshalb spricht
man lieber von einer Volkssprache die
fränkisch würde ich jetzt mal sagen
beeinflusst war oder die fränkische
Richtung gehen so würde ich das so würde
ich die Sprache die keine große von von
klein auf mitbekommen hat umschreiben
aber man muss natürlich gleich dazu
sagen dass er auch die anderen Sprachen
konnte also dass er auch Latein sprechen
konnte und dass er auch das romanische
verstanden hat romanisch
Sicherheit verstehen
ursprünglich römischen Gebieten
gesprochen hat das wohl wahre in Italien
diese Entwicklung gibt es ja überall
aber auch das muss er verstanden haben
ich glaube das wird sehr deutlich genial
wir haben den die Menschen in
karlsrisiken Reich miteinander
kommuniziert Frau Hartmann ich meine
wenn einer aus dem Gebiet des heutigen
Hamburg oder sagen wir mal nur Aachen
mit einem aus sagen wir mal perpignon
kommunizieren wollte wie lief denn das
ging das nur über Latein oder haben die
sich auch so verstanden das ist
natürlich die Frage von welchen
Schichten wir da sprechen dass die
geistige Oberschicht auf Latein
verständigt hat ist ganz sicher wenn man
an Karls hofkreis denkt Alkohol aus Jork
der von den Inseln kam seine Berater die
aus Italien kamen und dann auch
diejenigen die im Frankenreich dann
Aufstiegen zu Gelehrten da war ganz klar
die Sprache Latein in der Sprache haben
sie sich dann auch Briefe und Gedichte
geschickt und was die einfacheren Leute
anbelangt ist natürlich die Frage ob sie
sich je begegnet sind jemand aus einer
einfacheren Schicht der aus Aachen oder
Hamburg stammte mit jemandem aus
Südfrankreich denn für die normalen
Menschen war die Mobilität in der Zeit
ja nicht besonders hoch die unfreien
waren sowieso an ihren Herren und an
die Scholle wie man das nennt gebunden
also an den Hof auf dem sie lebten und
arbeiteten und wenn man dann etwa an
Wallfahrer denkt da ist vielleicht noch
am ehesten eine Begegnung anzunehmen
aber es ist eben auch das Problem der
Quellen dass unsere Quellen diese Dinge
nicht aussprechen weil es für die
damaligen Menschen eine
Selbstverständlichkeit war wie sie sich
gekleidet haben wie sie gesprochen haben
was sie gegessen haben und das hat man
nicht extra in die Quellen
reingeschrieben insofern können wir
solche Fragen eben nur sehr schwer
beantworten also kommen wir mal zu dem
was die Quellen sagen Herr Weinfurter
und zu Karls Verdiensten das heißt ja
immer er sei der begr der europäischen
Wissenskultur gewesen das ja doch ein
großes Wort das heißt es denn das ist
ein großes Wort und man muss schon sagen
eher selbst kann das gar nicht alleine
gewesen sein aber er ist derjenige
gewesen der sicher einen großen Anteil
daran hatte das wird man sagen können
Wissensvermittlung aus der Antike in das
europäische Mittelalter hinein und damit
in die europäische Kultur das hängt
damit zusammen dass er einen Kreis von
Gelehrten den Verrat man schon
angesprochen hat
der geistigen Elite kann man sagen aus
seiner Zeit an seinen Hof geholt hat das
waren erstklassige Wissenschaftler das
muss man sich mal klar machen
und diese Wissenschaftler haben ein ja
Bildungsprogramm entwickelt also
verkürzt gesagt und haben für dieses
Bildungsprogramm die antiken Autoren die
antike Literatur die antike Philosophie
Sprachwissenschaften und so weiter
übernommen und zugrunde gelegt auch die
antike Methode wissenschaftsmethode ja
das heißt die sieben freien Künste ja
dann müsste man auch mal drauf zu
sprechen kommen die sieben freien Künste
das heißt also die trivialen Künste
heute nennen wir sie die trivialen
Künste das ist die das ist
Rhetorik Grammatik und die Dialektik
also das sind das sind Künste die wir
heute ja schon in einer gehobene Fähre
leben würden gut also und diese Texte
werden in Mengen abgeschrieben und sind
dadurch überhaupt überliefert dass man
sich immer klar machen wir hätten ja aus
der Antike nur einen ganz kleinen Teil
über liefert weil das alles auf
verführungsgeschrieben wurde und heute
vernichtet wäre aber in seiner Zeit
wurde das auf
nachhaltiges Parlament geschrieben und
damit haben wir das war denn diese
Wissenskultur ein ein allgemeiner
Fortschritt der das ganze Reich erfasste
oder war das nur ein kleiner Teil der
Bevölkerung die Eliten in den Klöstern
die Gelehrten die davon erfasst wurden
ja zunächst mal natürlich die Eliten
aber ich denke man muss auch hinzufügen
dass die Vereinheitlichung der Schrift
eben diese karolingische minusgil die
unter ihm geschaffen wurde und mit deren
Hilfe ja die Klassiker abgeschrieben
wurden dass das auch noch weitergewiesen
hat denn hätte kalt ich diese
schriftreform mit Hilfe seiner Gelehrten
ins Werk gesetzt hätte er auch dieses
Riesenreich nicht in der Form regieren
können und damit hätte er gar nicht sich
in den letzten Jahren relativ dauerhaft
in Aachen aufhalten können wenn er nicht
durch diese Reformen und natürlich dann
auch seine Amtsträger eine
Vereinheitlichung des Reiches geschaffen
hat und diese Schrift das kann man ja
auch nicht hoch genug bewerten ist ja
noch unsere heutige Schriftsteller
dass wir heute die schriftkreis des
großen sprechen für dich schreiben mir
scheint auch wichtig zu betonen diesen
Geist des Systems also es gibt eine
Systematik im wissen aber auch in
anderen Bereichen wir haben von der
Schriftkultur gesprochen aber zum
Beispiel auch
in dem wirtschaftlichen Bereich also das
ab 794
also nicht nur allein Karl der Große
aber sagen wir mal diese Regierung oder
die hofverwaltung setzt für ganz Europa
des damaligen der damaligen Zeit ein
einheitliches System ein Pfund wird 20
Schilling und ein Schilling wird 12
dinaren und dieses Duo Dezimalsystem
besteht sogar ein Großbritannien bis
1971 also Masse gesetzt also wir feiern
Karl das wissenskönig aber wie die Stanz
den um den Menschen selber ist es
richtig dass der selber zwar lesen
konnte aber Schreiben nicht so sehr Frau
Hartmann ja das ist für uns heutzutage
eine Einheit lesen und schreiben können
das war im Mittelalter aber durchaus
anders die Leute konnten lesen aber sie
mussten nicht unbedingt schreiben können
und es gibt ja eben bei Einhard die
berühmte schöne Geschichte das Karl in
seinen schlaflosen Nachtstunden dann in
seinen späten Jahren noch schreiben
lernen wollte und das geübt hat und es
ist sicherlich keine Ausnahme gewesen
das Bild von Karl ist ja ziemlich
schillern zum einen der wissbegierige
Reformator Reformator zum anderen der
brutale schlechter Sie Herr weinfutter
nenn ihn ihn in ihrem Buch den heiligen
Barbaren wie passt denn das zusammen
also der Begriff die Bezeichnung war war
er hat für uns heute ja so diesen
allgemeinen payorativen Klang vielleicht
ein brutaler Mensch und was auch immer
aber in dieser Zeit über die wir hier
handeln war der Barbar klar definiert
das war der nicht Romane klare Sache
Baba ist da nicht Romane so benennt sich
übrigens auch der Einsatz in Insider ich
bin ein Barbara sagt Einhard aber mein
Latein ist nicht so schnell aber
eigentlich bin ich ein ungebildeter also
das ist der Barbara ironisch damals in
der eigenen Definition
auf der anderen Seite klingt aber beim
Barbara natürlich schon auch durch dass
er einfach ein ein brutaler Kriegsführer
war also nach unseren Begriffen nach
unseren Vorstellungen deshalb dieser
Barbara ja wo diese zwei Seiten
anklingen
er will übrigens dieses Barbaren tun
überwinden das sagte immer die barriers
unsere barbaries die möchte ich
überwinden und der heilige ist klar er
wird heilig gesprochen
64 man kann fast sagen von von Friedrich
Barbarossa gerade zu persönlich den
Barbarossa holt die Gebeine aus den aus
dem Sarkophag und legt sie also
transferiert sie in in den neuen
Schreien der wollte selber gerne mal
heilen hier er wollte mit dem Heiligen
in Verbindung geraten und der heilige
karl ist natürlich der heißheilige dann
ja damit bekommt das Reich eine
Heiligkeit die an die Seite der heiligen
Kirche gestellt werden kann
Iglesia steht nun dem heiligen Reich dem
Sack kommen Imperium gegenüber da möchte
der Franzose doch sagen dass sie sein
handheiliger der ist ja
von der Kirche
anerkannt worden während Ludwig der
elfte unserer Saarlouis ein richtiger
heiliger ist wir haben auch einen
richtigen heiligen Heinrich den zweiten
nicht vergessen also jeder hat so seine
heiligen Frau Hartmann richtig ist der
die These dass dieser heilige für den
Tod seines Bruders Kachelmann gesorgt
hat um die Alleinherrschaft ausüben zu
können das war ja wenig heilig das ist
eben auch umstritten da muss man
wirklich sagen dass wir keine Quelle
haben die dieses behauptet das ist eine
Theorie von einzelnen Historikern
sondern wir haben im Gegenteil eine
Urkunde kurz vorm Tod Karlmanns in aus
der hervorgeht dass er krank war und
dass er in saremie deras begraben werden
wollte eben nicht jetzt Pandemie weil
das ja eben auch schon als Argument
gebracht wurde dass Karl nicht
unschuldig ist an seinem Tod wenn ihm
sein Bruder nicht in der Grablege
sondern nie beigesetzt wird also dafür
gibt es überhaupt keinen Beleg was man
wohl sagen muss ist natürlich dass er
sich nach dem sein Bruder gestorben war
dann dessen Reich ganz zielstrebig
angeeignet hat und auch dessen Söhne
ausgeschaltet
es kam ihm gelegen aber ich denke man
darf nicht für den Tod seines Bruders
verantwortlich machen und ich möchte
noch eins zu hören die Mutter sagen was
man bei Karl auch denke ich immer sagen
muss ist dieses Genie der Freundschaft
und dieses große Charisma was er gehabt
haben muss wenn man ihn charakterisiert
dass es ihm eben gelungen ist die Leute
sehr an sich zu binden und eben nicht
zuletzt auch diejenigen mit denen er
diese großen Reformen durchgezogen hat
Paulus Diakonus aus Italien kommt ins
Frankenreich weil sein Bruder sich an
einem Aufstand beteiligt hat und will
für seinen Bruder bitten und er bleibt
im Frankenreich schreibt für Karl
wichtige Quellen also das kann man
eigentlich nur so erklären dass der
König ein großes Charisma hatte was mich
an ihrem Buch am meisten fasziniert hat
mit am meisten fasziniert hat er
Weinfurter ist die These das Karl vor
allem eines propagiert hat nämlich
Eindeutigkeit in der Schrift im Glauben
in den inneren Strukturen seines Reiches
und wer einer scherte aus war das so
also ich nenne das Eindeutigkeit in den
Quellen kommt der Begriff Norma vor das
oder Norma das heißt also die
Eindeutigkeit der rechtheit der
Richtigkeit
ich denke schon dass man das bei ihm
sagen kann er versucht das ist ja auch
schon angesprochen worden einheitliche
Gewichte einheitliche Währung das ist
natürlich das einfachste aber ein
einheitliche Schrift haben wir auch
schon angesprochen aber es geht auch
weiter er will klare Werte setzen klare
Werte und diese Werte sind natürlich die
kirchlichen Gesetze und Normen und die
will er durchführen und durchziehen und
das ist für mich auch eine Frage
der Eindeutigkeit des Verhaltens und der
Eindeutigkeit der der Kriterien für das
für dasjenige was das Richtige und das
Gerichte ist Nachfrage hat er da nicht
aber Wasser gepredigt und Wein getrunken
denn er selber hat sich ja doch eher
mal zweideutig gern Verhalten was der
Frauen Geschichten betraf äh da galten
ja die Gebote der christlichen Kirche
nicht vor ihm und wie wir lesen unter
anderem ja bei ihnen hat er vom Mannes
Kraft nur so gestrotzt und deshalb
dieses Jahr schon bald nach seinem Tod
ich zitiere er werde in der Hölle auf
ewig an seinem lustorgan gezwickt werden
Zuschauer um Himmels willen warum denn
das
also ich würde mal sagen dass wir den
ganzen Bereich eh und Partnerschaft für
diese Zeit nichts mit späteren
Situationen vergleichen dürfen oder mit
späteren Regelungen in der Kirche wir
sind in einer Zeit in der die Kirche
erst damit beginnt
enormen und Gesetze für Eheschließung
oder Ehe Scheidung zu entwickeln also
insofern ist Karl das so in einer
Zwischenphase könnte man ihm zu gut
erhalten
aber
andererseits wird man sagen müssen es
gibt schon in der Tat vorher erste
Versuche schon unter seinem Vater Pipin
die Dinge der sich übrigens auch trennen
wollte von seiner Frau aber dann auf zu
reden das Papstes dann doch bei seiner
bertraler geblieben ist
es gibt also in seiner Zeit schon erste
Ansätze die etwas strenger zu fassen ja
die Eva pflichtungen und das die
Trennung
nicht mehr so leicht zu machen aber wir
müssen immer sehen dass es noch
fließende Grenzen gibt zwischen
dem was wir feste oder legale Ehefrau
nennen und den Geliebten und früher hat
man sie Friedl Frauen genannt und also
denjenigen die Frauen Friede Frau
herkommt
der
solche Ehen oder solche Verbindungen
charakterisiert bei denen Frauen
angeblich nur
für sich persönlich in eine Beziehung
eintreten und nicht die ganze Sippe
dranhängt aber müssen wir ja immer sehen
dass Eheschließungen in dieser Zeit und
das geht durch das ganze Mittelalter
hindurch ja nicht eine Entscheidung eine
Frau eine einzelne Frau war ja diese
Frau ist vielleicht 12 13 14 Jahre alt
damals wurden Frauen in dem Alter
verheiratet sondern das waren ja oft
auch nicht sehr lange
ja das die ganze Familie musste hier
zustimmen und musste eine Vertrag
schließen mit der anderen Familie und
das war bei der Frieden Frauen nicht so
ja also diese These ist ja eigentlich
überholen
okay und es gibt
also der Begriff Friede Ehe kommt aus
ist Anfang des 20 Jahrhunderts geprägt
worden und aus literarischen Quellen
genommen aber aus den Quellen des
neunten Jahrhunderts kann man diesen
Begriff eben nicht erschließen und
insofern muss man bei den fränkischen
Königen vor Karl und auch in der Zeit
kann man eigentlich nur zwischen einer
legitimen Ehefrau und einer Konkubine
eben einer Freundin
damit wir mal über die Größenordnungen
uns klar werden wie viele legitime
Ehefrauen hat Karl gehabt wie viele
Konkubine wie viele Kinder und welche
davon waren den legitim das ist ein
kompliziertes Thema es die ersten beiden
Ehefrauen hat Karl der Große aus
unterschiedlichen politischen Gründen
verstoßen dann wissen wir sicher von
zwei weiteren Ehefrauen Hildegard die
eben die Mutter aller legitimen das
heißt für die Nachfolge vorgesehenen
Söhne Karls war dann als vierte Ehefrau
fast Radar die vielleicht politisch den
meisten Einfluss hatte Karl aber nur
zwei Töchter geboren hat und ob liud
Guard dann seine fünfte Ehefrau war oder
nur die Konkubine ist eben umstritten
anbelangt da wissen wir nur von den
konkubin die Karl Kinder geboren haben
es können also eine ganze Reihe gewesen
sein die er hatte die ihm keine Kinder
geboren haben und die dann sozusagen
nicht bis in die Quellen geschafft haben
Einhard hat da auch merkwürdige
Aussetzer in dem er nämlich auch in
einem Fall behauptet der Name einer
Konkubine falle ihm nicht mehr ein
obwohl der bekannt gewesen sein muss
denn um 840 weiß ein Autor der einharz
wieder dann herausgibt noch einen Namen
mehr also das ist ganz damit ist auch
ganz klar dass auch schon bei den
Zeitgenossen Karls Kritik an seinem
Sexualverhalten da war nur er hat sich
darüber hinweggesetzt würde ich die
Rolle spielten denn diese Ehefrauen
hatten die irgendwelchen Einfluss
vielleicht sogar politischen Einfluss
gibt es bei all den Ehefrauen eine die
da besonders hervorsticht wie war das
also
wenn man den Quellen glauben darf hatte
seine vierte Ehefrau fast Rada politisch
vielleicht den größten Einfluss bei
Hildegard muss man eben sagen Hildegard
muss um die 14 gewesen sein als er sie
geheiratet hat und war in den elf Jahren
Ehe bevor sie dann gestorben ist
permanent schwanger die hat sicherlich
auch keine Interesse und keine
Möglichkeiten gehabt irgendwie
politisch einzugreifen bei lidguard eben
der fünften entweder fünf der Ehefrau
oder Konkubine da ist deutlich dass
vieles über sie läuft also etwa die
verteil wir erwarten Beute da gibt es
Briefe eben wo
al-guard auseinandersetzen
Karl eben auch an die Kirchen und
Klöster seines Reiches gegeben hat und
die Verteilung lief über Leopard aber es
ist natürlich immer nur punktuell in den
Quellen mal erwähnt wenn die Frauen
Einfluss hatten spontane Frage kamen die
meisten Frauen eigentlich eher aus dem
Germanischen oder dem romanischen teils
eindeutig aus dem Germanischen aha also
das ist sehr interessante
das sind sicher zwei Dinge das eine ist
seine
Vertrautheit mit diesen Völkern und auch
die Verbindungen die es zwischen den
Völkern im Adels in Arzt Ebene gibt und
zum anderen sind das auch ganz gezielte
politische
Situationen
holt sich eine Frau aus dem
alemannischen Hochadel kann man sagen
das ist diese Hildegard die ihm dann die
weil Alemannien zum Reich seines Bruders
gehört hat
und er will seinen Bruder daraus
dringend indem er die führende
Adelsfamilie der gerolde wie sie heißen
an sich bindet und diese junge Frau da
eben über die junge Frau die Verbindung
herstellt also das gibt es auch das muss
man auch sehen und das gleiche gilt
übrigens auch für die Frau die aus dem
Haus des langobardenkönigs Holts ja das
ist auch so ein Versuch der war
vollkommen scheint hat seine Mutter ja
eigentlich hat ja diese Frau mit ins
Reich gebracht und in dem Moment wo sein
Bruder stirbt und Karl wird allein
Herrscher hat seine Mutter politisch
ausgespielt und die Ehe mit der der
Tochter des Landes baden können er
leistet sich auf Frauen die er liebt da
bin ich mir ganz sicher ja das kann man
sonst also er hat sie beide Dinge ganz
stark beeindruckt waren
der große also er hat das diktiert
bestimmt aber er fragt auch nach
Nachrichten dass seine Frau damals in
nicht genug Nachrichten gibt auch von
den Kindern also an gewissen Zeichen
sieht man doch das über die
außenpolitische diplomatische politische
Ebene doch auch gewisse persönliche er
war ein Familienmenschen genau
die von Konkubine
so in der Erziehung so in der Kindheit
durften sie auch schreiben lesen wie war
das das haben sie natürlich gelernt und
die waren immer am Hof dabei das ist
ganz also außerordentlich
ja bemerkenswert dass sie dass sie auch
immer mitgenommen werden dass sie auf
der Jagd dabei sind ja das geschildert
wird wie sie da auf den strahlenden
schimmeln in die Jagd reiten und das
sind nachher dabei sind und an diesen
köstlichen verlorener Wein trinken und
das ist eine ja Familie in der die
Töchter eine ganz große Rolle spielen
und in den Brief den hermonie
angesprochen wird
erkundigt er sich auch ausdrücklich wie
geht's meinen alles süßesten Töchtern ja
das ist einfach natürlich auch sagen
muss dass er die Töchter am Hof behält
und ihnen keine legitimen ihn gestattet
um eben keine politische Konkurrenz in
Form von Schwiegersöhnen zu er da zeigt
sich natürlich auch dass er sehr
weitblickend war in politischer Hinsicht
um da eben keine Konkurrenz zu schaffen
insofern ist es im Grunde doppelt
deutlich dass er die Töchter am Hof hält
und die Töchter sind ja dann auch
Beziehungen eingegangen aus denen auch
Kinder hervorgegangen sind die dann auch
wieder versorgt wurden und am Hof waren
aber ich denke aus all dem wird schon
deutlich dass die Familie für eine große
Rolle gespielt hat und wenn man sich den
Hof in Aachen in Karls späten Jahren
vorstellt muss es ja ein richtiges
weiberregiment gewesen sein mit den
zahlreichen Töchtern und Enkelinnen sehr
germanisches weiberregiment da brauchen
wir jetzt mal darum Mann
für alle diese Frauen germanischen
Frauen war er bestimmt auch ein
attraktiver Mann also ich meine immer
groß ein Meter 84 da laut also auf jeden
Fall über ein Meter 80
sehr groß für die aus medizinischen
Untersuchungen genau also kein kleiner
Franzose wenn man das so sagen will
man hat bestätigt das auch ein Herz sagt
er was sieben seiner Füße groß
war 27 cm es war nicht das Fußmaß
sondern sagt ausdrücklich seiner Füße
aber einer hat sagt auch dass der
spätere Karl einen Bauch und eine helle
deswegen würde ich sagen er muss eben
auch Charisma stark werden damit wir das
Thema jetzt richtig abschließen wollen
wir doch noch mal wissen was für einen
Typ Karl was für ein Typ Frau Karl
bevorzugt hat also wir haben erstmal
gehört germanisch aber was ist denn
ansonsten so schwarz rot blond oder beim
das egal also bei wissen wir dass Sie
also muss man annehmen dass sie blond
war so beschrieben wird hell und und ihr
Haar und also ich das ist mein Eindruck
sage ich mal das steht nicht drin sie
war blonds aber so wie sie beschrieben
wird bei den anderen Frauen könnte ich
das gar nicht sagen muss ich sagen wie
sie ausgesehen haben oder
aber Sie müssen alle schön gewesen sein
da bin ich überzeugt davon ich glaube da
war er schon ein ein Kenner das beruhigt
und wirklich sehr und wenn wir jetzt
schon beim Thema Laster sind
Anführungszeichen die Wissenschaft
erklärt uns ja dass bei Gastmählern zu
jener Zeit das Trinken ja das Saufen er
die Regel als die Ausnahme gewesen ist
das hat Karl der Franke sich daran
gehalten also natürlich hat er auch
mitgedrungen und mitgegessen und wir
haben eine ganze Reihe von Quellen wo es
heißt er wollte dich gutes gebratenes
Fleisch und nicht irgendwie so ein
gekochtes das hat immer abgelehnt oder
oder auch in den Gedichten der Gelehrten
heißt es wir wollen nicht immer diesen
Brei essen ja sondern wir wollen Fleisch
essen und wir wollen und und Wein wurde
natürlich getrunken das haben sie in all
diesen ja festgedichten die von den
Gelehrten eigens für diese Gelegenheiten
getextet wurden dort auch vorgetragen
worden sind ja haben sie das erzählt das
waren immer Gelage wer war einer hat
sagt er auch Karl sei sehr mäßig im
trinken gewesen also das mit dem Fleisch
ist klar
nicht an den Rat seiner Ärzte gehalten
hat die ihm von gebratenem Fleisch
abgeraten haben das hat er nicht
übernommen aber also für das Reich galt
Eindeutigkeit strenge Regeln er selber
hat das liberal interpretiert Frage
konnte er sich das erlauben zu Lebzeiten
weil er
gewissermaßen mächtiger als der Papst
gewesen war der oberste der Kirche der
enormen setzte auch wenn er durch den
Papier als zum Kaiser gekrönt wurde
es ist schon ein paar mal gesagt worden
das ist einfach seine Ausstrahlung
gewesen seine Autorität und auch die Art
und Weise wie er seine Dinge durch
nutzen konnte also auch seine
Durchsetzungskraft das muss man ja sehen
in einer Zeit in der es keine
Institutionen gibt muss die persönliche
Überzeugungskraft entscheidend sein und
das hat auch dazu geführt dass man ihm
das nachgesehen hat und er war ein
erfolgreicher Kriegsmann das muss man
auch sehen er hat seine Heere immer
Erfolg fast immer es gibt auch ein paar
Ausnahmen erfolgreich wieder also aus
einem Krieg zurückführen können schwer
beladen mit Beute und da waren alle
zufrieden denn sie gehörten sowohl zu
den guten wie auch zu den Sieg reichen
und was will ein ein ein einherführer
sonst noch an anderen Lob und heraus und
Auszeichnung also insofern muss man
sagen hat man ihm das nachgesehen
war ein schwacher Papst der Papst gerade
der Karlson hat war ein eher schwacher
Papst in Rom der ja auch flieht nach
einem Attentat und Hilfe bei Karl sucht
der war sicherlich nicht in der Lage im
Vorschriften zu machen
wer hat es versucht aber das wollen wir
nicht ansprechen
weil sie sagen da handelte er ganz im
Sinne der Kirche indem er an den Rändern
seines Reiches die Christianisierung
vorantrieb Stichwort Sachsenkriege da
hat er ja einen großen Gegner den
germanischen Sachsen Herzog Widukind war
dafür Karl nur der Heere Glaube des
Motiv oder schlicht und einfach auch das
Bestreben sein Reich und seine Macht zu
vergrößern
also ich glaube für jeden König damals
und auch später ist das Reich
auszudehnen eine eine
Selbstverständlichkeit und wenn man auch
obendrein Augustus also Imperator Kaiser
ist es gehört dazu aber natürlich da war
er weniger erfolgreich wenn man an
Pyrenäen oder Richtung Spanien damals da
gibt es auch diese Niederlage und deiner
später die terrarisiert in der Form des
Roland Liedes vielleicht sprechen wir
noch mal darüber aber
nicht für alle unsere Zuschauer sofort
ein Begriff also das kann mit seiner
Ehre Richtung Spanien gegen behauptet
man in diesen Chansons die in dieser
Literatur des 12 jahrhunderts geben die
Zara sehenden damals gekämpft hat also
sie muslimischen genauen wo wo natürlich
bei dieser Schlacht in orange Wales 73
wo dann diese Niederlage wo Roland ein
der volksmänner von
Karl dem Großen da getötet wurde und so
weiter man weiß heute zu Tage dass es
nicht um
zarazenen also Muslime oder Araber ging
sondern um Basken aber letzten Endes
ging ja nicht mehr nach Frankreich
genau
aber sagen wir mal da diese Front
Richtung Süden war ihm nicht sehr so
beliebt während natürlich die Sachsen
Kriege fast 30 Jahren man muss immer
wenn man von Sachsen spricht sofort dazu
sagen dass das nicht das heutige Sachsen
ist ja Niedersachsen
hat sozusagen gleich hinter Deutz
begonnen dass das war ein kleiner
Streifen rechtsrheinisch war und dann
beginnt Sachsen und reicht bis zur Elbe
also und das ist ein riesengebiet
gewesen und verschiedene Stämme und
verschiedene Stimme richtig gemacht dazu
soziale und politische Gebilde so das
heißt verschiedene Stämme erklären Sie
uns das mal verschiedene sächsische
Stämme verstehende sächsische Stämme die
verschiedene Anführer hatten und
insofern konnte Karl wenn er nach einer
sachsenschlacht zu einem Friedensschluss
gekommen ist meinen damit hat er jetzt
Sachsen erobert aber im nächsten Jahr
hat sich in anderer Teil Stamm erhoben
gebunden
und insofern ist das im Grunde das Haupt
Erklärungsmuster warum diese
Sachsenkriege 30 Jahre gedauert haben es
war nicht ein Anführer wie du Kind war
der prominenteste aber eben nur einer
und die anderen haben sich dann an
diesen Friedensschluss nicht gebunden
gefühlt und dann wieder losgeschlagen
und insofern gedauert über die
Geschichte mit diesem Video Kinder ist
ja fast schon ein Symbol Karl kontra
vido kennt ja fast schon auch ein Mythos
geworden auch im 20 Jahrhundert wie wie
ging das aus die Geschichte selbst das
kann man schnell erzählen also wie du
kindischen Bereich man weiß nicht sehr
viele über aber er war dann in den 70er
Jahren der Anführer des Widerstands ähm
77 Jahre 770er Jahre sage ich jetzt mal
und
nach einigen Jahren unterwirft er sich
und uns wird nimmt die Taufe an und ist
dann relativ Weg ist sofort verschwunden
von der Geschichte man rätselt heute was
ist mit videokind passiert es gibt eine
Video Kind Verehrung in engern und
sagen wir mal in westfälischen Bereich
und dort glaubt man ja immer noch dass
da seine Güte oder seine Grab liegt uns
es gibt eine andere These die sagt dass
er in
auf der Reichenau interniert wurde und
dort auch gestorben ist also
es gibt keine Kraft nein das es gibt
aber einen Eintrag von einem milokind in
einem in einer gedächtnisliste von der
Reichenau also insofern wissen wir das
nicht so genau aber natürlich wird
wieder Kind später ja das ist gar keine
Frage und zwar vor allen Dingen im 19
und 20 Jahrhundert im sogenannten
Dritten Reich wo man Karl einerseits als
Sachsen schlechter die formiert hat vor
allem Himmler hat sich da hervorgetan
und andere zum anderen haben sich die
Nazis gern auf ihn berufen und als
Vorbild angesehen wie du Kind aber auch
aber ich sage jetzt mal Hitler und Karl
passt das überhaupt zusammen
also sagen wir mal
das war ein Problem für den
Nationalsozialismus denn auf der einen
Seite haben sie in Widukind eine
sächsische eine germanische Lichtgestalt
gesehen und das war ganz in ihrem Sinne
so ihre
arabischen Ideologie
während Karl eigentlich zunächst mal
keine große Rolle gespielt hat das fängt
übrigens schon früher an dass in
Deutschland keiner der große gar nicht
so auf anderen
auch der preußische Kaiser hat sich
eigentlich eher an andere Personen
angelehnt etwa an Barbarossa ja der
Rotbart wird fortgesetzt durch den
Weißbart ja das haben wir ja ja aber
kein großer Dritter eigentlich eher
etwas zurück und es kommt immer wieder
diese Vorstellung auch schon im 19
Jahrhundert dass keiner der große der
Sachsen schlechter war der also dieses
germanische
germanische Tradition das germanischen
Volk unterdrückt hat und das wird vom
Nationalsozialismus am Anfang
aufgenommen ja das sind vor allen Dingen
alfred Rosenberg und von Schirach die
das
ganz genau
der dabei war ja videokind der ist so
ein Denkmal und die Sachsen sollten ihr
Denkmal bekommen aber dann kommt eben
Hitler schon oder 35
Parteitag und das sagt
Hitler zu
Rosenberg was machen wir den Kran nicht
so schlecht
dieser karl hat die germanischen Stimme
vereint ja damit kommt er ja die
Eroberungspolitik das ist natürlich was
und dass man anknüpfen kann womit man
mal wieder sieht wie man die einzelnen
mittelalterlichen Personen
instrumentalisieren kann
im sogenannten Dritten Reich am Ende
auch eine ssdivision mit dem zusammen
shalomagne Karl der Große die hat dir
als letzte der Getreuen Hitler bis zum
Tod verteidigt und sich erst am zweiten
Mai der Roten Armee ergeben das waren ja
Franzosen Elsässer wie die bewertet man
das heute in Frankreich also nicht nur
ja da hat man gesagt also fast
ausschließlich aus französischen oder
essischen Soldaten es ist bestimmt nicht
so gewesen aber immerhin und die in dem
kollektiven Gedächtnis wenn sie in
Frankreich Namen heutzutage die Vision
schade man aussprechen es ist immer noch
ein wunder Punkt aber andererseits da
haben sich versammelt natürlich Leute
die geglaubt haben 43 und 44 45 für ein
gewisses Europa für ein abendländisches
christliches Europa gegen solche wissen
muss und so weiter aber das da der Name
auch instrum realisiert wurde ist auch
ganz klar aber das bleibt noch sehr
umstritten und noch ein ein wunder Punkt
natürlich ich wollte nur sagen dieser
Instrumentalisierung Charlie Mann
Sachsen Kriege hat auch in der
französischen Monarchie Mittelalter
funktioniert zum Beispiel 1200 14
übrigens auch ein Geburtstag im Jahr
2014 große Schlacht von Frankreich der
französische König Philipp Augustus
gegen den Kaiser den deutschen Kaiser
Orte den 4 und da behaupten schon die
Konnekt später das Philip Augustus als
Nachfolger von Karl dem Großen denn
Sachsen König den Sachsen unter den
vierten besiegt hat also schon damals
hat man mit solchen Bildern gespielt und
solche Instrumentalisierung gab es ja
auch weit nach dem Mittelalter noch
Beispiele Napoleon der als Herrscher das
kontinentalen Europas nach Aachen reist
um das Grab von Karl dem Großen
aufzusuchen was war denn da sein Motiv
1806 ist der da in Aachen ja und er
meint er realisiert wirklich was Karl
der Große damals vor ihm realisiert hat
und übrigens aus dem gleichen Jahr 1806
stammt ein Bild das noch in Frankreich
zu sehen ist von
Ärger also das berühmte Portrait von von
Napoleon auf seinen Turm und was trägt
er ein Zepter und wer steht da oben auf
dem Zepter Karl der Große also da ist
die Kontinuitätslinie wirklich vorhanden
in dem Kopf von Napoleon reden wir zum
Abschluss über Karl der Große und Europa
für auch eine Instrumentalisierung nur
versuchte die Grenzen des Frankenreiches
verliefen ja ähnlich wie die Grenzen der
früheren Europäischen Gemeinschaft von
Eisenach bis zu den Pyrenäen gleichsam
und die Frage ist braucht man heute Karl
den Großen für die europäische Idee
frage ich sie mal alle
also es wird immer schwieriger sage ich
mal warum weil Europa längst
die Grenzen des romanisch germanischen
überschritten hat längst sind große
Bereiche des Ostens dazu gekommen also
das östlichen Europa
und wir reichen wir greifen ja noch
weiter nun also in das in den
Mittelmeerraum hinein das ist dann nicht
mehr
Karl der Große der dafür stehen kann
also der gemeine Malteser und der
gemeine Rumäne kann mit Karl wenig
anfangen oder vor allen Dingen wenn wir
auch dann wenn wir auch sagen
muslimische Bereiche mit einbeziehen und
das ist ja längst der Fall das machen
wir ja schon lange die können mit keinem
großen ja überhaupt nichts anfangen ganz
im Gegenteil ja das Teil der Große hat
eine Politik getrieben die überhaupt
nicht auf Integration der Religionen
Ausfahrt das kann man wirklich nicht
sagen ja also deshalb ist man heute das
ja zurückhaltend geworden auch wenn er
ganz wesentliche Grundlagen für die
europäische Kultur gelegt hat da gibt es
eben da gibt es keinen Zweifel und
deshalb gibt es diese beiden Seiten und
wir können heute sagen dass diese
Impulse die er gegeben hat für eine
europäische Kultur die über Jahrhunderte
gewirkt hat die vor allen Dingen auch in
der Wissenskultur
sagen wir mal immer wieder weitergewirkt
hat man darf nicht einmal darf das nicht
linear sehen aber man muss ja zum
Beispiel klar doch deutlich darauf
hinweisen dass die Universitäten die
Wissenschaftszentren an sich die
Wahrheit Suchenden Einrichtungen ja aus
dem Mittelalter kommen aus dem 12
Jahrhundert im und im Grunde aufbauen
auf die Grundlagen auf das Fundament das
in der zeitreises großen gelegt wurden
also insofern hat er immer mit Europa zu
tun aber
eben mit diesen Einschränkungen dass
Europa heute viel mehr Völker und viel
mehr Kulturen mit einbezieht das ist das
eine und das andere ist dass wir heute
ohne hin
nicht mehr so ganz sicher sind ob wir
nicht die Globalität viel höher ansetzen
müssen als Europa aus der europäische
Idee wie sehen Sie das Rad mal also ich
denke das Karl als kulturelle
Integrationsfigur für Europa schon
taugen kann oder genommen werden kann
denn es sind die Grundlagen unserer
Kultur was wir hier ja auch schon
besprochen haben mit Schrift und
lateinischer Bildung und natürlich klar
auch die Universitäten man darf es eben
nicht
geographisch nehmen sozusagen sondern
man muss das denke ich kulturell nehmen
als integrations wo soll denn die
Europäische Union ansonsten historisch
Vorbild und Halt finden die braucht ja
dringend halt umsehen kann man da kann
nicht trotz alledem als Vorbild
sozusagen stilisieren also würden sie
den Gemeinden Franzosen fragen
würde sofort sagen schade Mann ist ein
Franzose bevor er Europäer ist das
halten wir mal fest dass die Antwort auf
unsere generelle Themen und die ich
sagte er ja und und die Aktualität die
Karl der Große gerade in Deutschland in
diesem Geburtsjahr
genießt ist auch ein Zeichen dafür dass
vielleicht das Land in dem Karl der
Große als Europäer am meisten gesehen
wird ist eben eher Deutschland für dich
so behaupten
weniger als Deutscher also es wird er
wird in Frankreich mehr als Franzose
gesehen als in Deutschland als
Deutschland
das hat komischerweise mit dem Kaisertum
zu tun
mit dem Mittelalter also mit dem
Mittelalter nicht mit dem mit dem
preußischen sondern mit dem
mittelalterlichen Kaisertum denn das
mittelalterliche Kaisertum knüpft an
keinen großen als Kaiser an und nicht
als nationalen ja
Urvater oder sowas überhaupt nicht ja er
ist und das Kaisertum überdeckt auch
sagen wir mal ganz diese diese deutsche
Einordnung und geht immer in eine
Ebene hinein die weit über Deutschland
hinausgreift also die irgendwo dann eben
eher europäisch ist und deshalb kann in
dieser deutschen Tradition Karl der
Große viel leichter ja ein wundervater
oder ein Symbol für Europa sein als in
Frankreich
wenn das so ist wie schön dann geht
meine Schlussfrage die absolute
Schlussfrage an sie alle fahren wir
wieder im weinfurt an dann machen wir
das im Uhrzeigersinn was ist der größte
Irrtum den Sie über Karl den Großen
immer schon mal aufklären wollten
also etwas was uns seit einiger Zeit
immer wieder mal verfolgt um das mal zu
formulieren er ist ja die These das ist
keine großen gar nicht gab also das ist
nicht nur keine großen nicht gab sondern
einfach 300 Jahre nicht gab gab es mal
so ein Buch so ja ja ein Buch darüber
das auch von der Presse mit großen
Vergnügen aufgenommen wurde und klar
sind Sensation ich hatte selbst einen
Journalisten bei mir und die Hunde was
machen Sie denn jetzt beruflich also
Gebiet weggefallen
und da wird ja damit argumentiert dass
bei der Kalenderreform irgendwie man
sich verrechnet hat und oder wenn man
die genau durch geht dann müssten also
300 Jahre gestrichen werden sonst würden
wir datumsmäßig also nicht mehr
übereinstimmen mit unserem heutigen
Datum darauf muss man gar nicht eingehen
sondern man muss nur sagen das was
damals in diesen drei Jahrhunderten
an Texten an
ja auch sonstigen Aktionen vorgenommen
wurde dass das so zahlreich ist und so
dicht ist dass wir so viele Quellen
haben dass wir einfach ja auch sehen
müssen dass diese 300 Jahre nichts
isoliert werden können sondern mit der
islamischen Geschichte zusammengehören
und mit der byzantinischen Geschichte
dass man sich niemals vorstellen kann
dass 300 Jahre erfunden worden Frau
Hartmann also mich würde eigentlich
nicht unbedingt die Aufklärung eines
Irrtums am meisten interessieren sondern
die Frage die mit Karls Kaisertum
zusammenhängt wir haben ja eben in den
Quellen die Information dass Karl wenn
er gewusst hätte dass die Kaiserkrönung
am Weihnachtstag 800 Anstände selbst an
diesem hohen Feiertag nicht in die
Kirche gegangen wäre wer sagt denn das
steht eben bei einhardt ist es das ist
eben
eine Frage ob das so stimmt man kann
sich ja gar nicht vorstellen dass Carl
von diesen ganzen Vorbereitungen nichts
gewusst hat aber es ist ja für die
Bedeutung auch des Kaisertums Karls
wichtig wie er dazu stand und wie
wirklich die Rolle des Papstes war man
hat schon verschiedene Erklärungen
gewagt aber man bekommt eben letztlich
aus den Quellen die Antwort nicht
insofern ist die Frage schwer zu
entscheiden also da noch eine neue
Quelle zu finden die uns das eindeutig
sagte wäre schön aber schöne
Herausforderung
ja aus der französischen Perspektive ist
Karl der Große sehr gut brauchbar der
wurde von dem Königtum von der Kirche
auch gebraucht aber auch von der
Universität ich meine wir sind alle
Universitätslehrer und in ihn in Paris
wird auch immer behauptet Karl der Große
hätte die Universität Paris gegründet
das stimmt natürlich nicht aber
interessant ist immer im Geschichte
sowohl die Wahrheit als auch die Lüge
oder die Legende warum hat man sowas
behauptet weil in Frankreich wenn Karl
der Große dann ist er auch eine Figur
des
stadtsmales und auch der Gründer der
Schule und so erklärt sich das und das
ist auch eine schöne Lüge die Geschichte
lehrt andauernd aber findet keine
Schüler sagt ein Sprichwort für uns gilt
das nicht für ihre Zuschauer wir haben
heute was gelernt ich danke Ihnen sehr
für ihre interessanten
Diskussionsbeiträge und Ihnen liebe
Zuschauer danke ich für ihr Interesse
bleiben sie uns treu